figure et l'oeil bonjour nous sommes en
direct ce mercredi après midi pour
parler de la variole du singe une
maladie qui a fait déjà trois cas en
france qui sont comptabilisés selon la
ministre de la santé brigitte
bourguignon et pour en parler je suis
avec marc cher qui marque chère qui
bonjour j'aurais une conscience au
figaro avec vous va décrypter un peu et
répondre à cette question est-ce qu'il
faut s'inquiéter mais d'abord on va
expliquer un peu ce qu'est ce qu'est
cette maladie d'où elle vient pourquoi
on en parle maintenant et tout au long
de cela et bien évidemment vous pouvez
poser vos questions on essaiera d'y
répondre au mieux du mieux qu'on peut
comme d'habitude marque la première
question que j'avais c'était c'est quoi
cette maladie de la variole du singe et
pourquoi on l'appelle comme ça alors la
variole du singe ça s'appelle la variole
parce que ça ressemble à la variole qui
a été éradiquée dans le monde qui est
une grande victoire de l'om est dans les
années 80 il n'y a plus du tout de
variole dans le monde en revanche il ya
sept variole du singe qui a été
identifié à très très longtemps dans une
île dans une animalerie à copenhague sur
des singes et c'est pour ça qu'on
l'appelle la variole du singe c'est
parce qu'elle a été repérée sur des
singes en 58 mais le premier cachet de
l'homme je crois que c'était dans les
années 1970 ça fait un peu penser à la
varicelle en fait avec d'autres signes
caractéristiques une grosse fièvre et
les ganglions qui gonfle
mal au crâne voilà et puis après cette
période de fièvre et cette période
d'incubation qui peut être assez longue
ça peut être entre de una jusqu'à deux
ou trois semaines hier que trois
semaines sans avoir de 2,5 tonnes de
sapins les symptômes commencent à
peuvent arriver enfin c'est ce que dit
l'om est sain mais là semble-t-il ça
arrive à un petit peu plus rapidement et
donc ça fait penser un peu à la
varicelle dans sa forme et c'est une
maladie relativement bénigne dans la
plupart des cas les gens et guérif tout
seul sans
sans traitement particulier alors voilà
mais on s'en inquiète un peu parce qu'il
ya eu des cas de mortalité en afrique
oui c'est une maladie qu'on connaît en
connais en afrique plutôt que c'est
l'afrique qui est touché et là ça va
toucher l'europe depuis quelques
semaines en fait ça qui se passe c'est
ça ou alors depuis le ce qui a trait
original c'est que il ya des
contaminations d'homme à homme ça on
n'avait jamais vu on avait déjà vu par
le passé dans les années
80 et 70 au nigeria et dans d'autres
pays dans lequel la
en afrique dans laquelle il yal cette
maladie qui vit de manière endémique
chez des animaux notamment des rongeurs
exister quoi et faire des cas et
d'ailleurs depuis quelques années le
nombre de cas avait tendance à augmenter
en afrique et on a déjà eu des épidémies
en aux états unis et en grande bretagne
mais c'était seulement sur des enfants
qui ont été contaminés alors en grande
bretagne c'était je crois via des
personnes qui rentrait de voyage et aux
etats-unis c'était par des chiens qui
avaient été contaminés eux mêmes par des
rongeurs et qui étaient eux contaminée
qui portait la maladie et qui venaient
d'afrique centrale ou d'afrique centrale
ou d'afrique de l'ouest et là la
différence c'est qu'il ya des cas qui
sont autochtones on a pu voir aux
autochtones donc en fait c'est des cas
qui apparaissent sans avoir voyagé avant
voilà c'est ça c'est des cas de personne
à personne donc depuis le début mais ça
a été repéré en grande bretagne avait un
premier cas comme disent les
spécialistes un cas index qui était une
personne qui venait du nigeria et après
il ya eu des cas et la plupart des
contaminations qu'on constate
aujourd'hui en europe et aux états unis
enfin il en amérique du nord est-ce
qu'il y en a il ya plus de cas au canada
quand
qu'aux états unis actuellement une
quinzaine de cas au canada et 3
seulement aux états unis confirmés
sont des cas qui ont été
autochtones donc des de personne à
personne on à une question d'un
internaute dont je vais pas dire le
pseudo par contre excusez moi mais est
ce que cela pourrait tourner comme le
virus le virus de la copie 19 qui est un
peu dans toutes les têtes puisque voilà
c'est cette épidémie déclarée il ya deux
ans et là il ya nouvelle épidémie qui
arrive est ce que il ya des similarités
est ce qu'il ya des choses ils
pourraient être des points communs alors
ce qui est commun c'est que c'est une
maladie qui nous vient d'ailleurs et
qu'on surveille
mais la gravité de cette maladie en tout
cas dans la forme actuelle
et est totalement différente il faut des
contacts rapprochés et long avec les
personnes qui sont porteuses du virus et
d'ailleurs on est porteur du virus pour
la variole du singe que à partir du
moment où des boutons apparaissent sur
le corps avant on n'est probablement pas
contagieux ce qui n'était pas le cas
avec l'aco vide avec le covin on pouvait
être contagieux avant d'avoir des de
développer des symptômes ce qui rendait
la la maladie peut compliquer à juguler
ça c'est un premier point et puis les
transmissions aériennes se font pas de
la même manière
donc les gouttelettes
il en faut plus a priori il en faudrait
plus est pendant un contact prolongé
plus long donc
d'après les spécialistes il n'y a pas
une mutation pour l'instant de la
maladie c'est un virus à adn dix minutes
beaucoup moins que celui du singe comme
un sas cov 2 donc il ya peu de risques
avec on connaisse une pandémie aussi
grave que celle du cabinet fin en
revanche il faut s'attendre à ce que le
nombre de cas augmente et il faut que
l'ensemble des pays prennent des mesures
alors il ya des pays comme la belgique
la grande-bretagne qui ont annoncé que
elle voulait mettre en place des
confinement de trois semaines pour les
personnes qui seraient porteuses de la
maladie ce qui n'est pas encore le cas
en france il n'y a pas eu d'annoncé
comparable en france disant voilà on va
m à résidence va contraindre à résidence
les personnes qui sont partout qu'à
contacter alors on a une question voilà
c'est plus un commentaire de sivan
serena qui dit on coupe les frontières
avec l'afrique sans aller jusque là est
ce qu'il ya sur des mesures comme on a
eu sur le sur le coït c'est à dire il
est des gens qui reviennent de deux pays
d'afrique sont mis en quarantaine aussi
ça sert à rien parce que d'abord les
gens sont peut-être porteurs du virus
sans le savoir et puis il les
contaminations sont déjà sur notre
territoire donc ça saab strictement à
rien de couper la relation avec
l'afrique
on l'a dit c'est assez proche de la
variole c'est pas forcément dangereux
mais sur les sur la soirée sur le mode
de transmission on vous avait parlé un
peu comment est-ce que ça ce virus se
transmet par don alors un des
spécialistes le dr antoine gessain qui
est une des rares personnes qui
connaissent cette maladie et qu'il a
suivi
depuis une dizaine d'années en afrique
xv a expliqué qu' il fallait le plus
souvent c'était par contact et c'était
souvent les
nourrissons qui étaient portés par leur
mère et qui
pouvaient toucher enfin la mère pouvait
être contaminé par l'enfant en touchant
les espèces de pustules les petits
boutons voilà donc ça c'est une mode de
contamination un autre mode de
contamination se serait par les
muqueuses mais on en sait un peu rien
mais on le suspecte
parce que la majorité des cas tu as été
identifiés sont dans la communauté
homosexuelle masculine et on pense qu'il
ya eu des rapports non protégés dans
cette communauté qui aurait pu entraîner
des contaminations ou par le sang mais
on ne sait pas ça en fait et on suppose
que les fluides biologiques qui ont pu
être répandus sur des tissus
puisse être contaminants mais on ne sait
pas combien de temps cette maladie est
très peu connue et très peu étudié oui
parce que c'est une maladie qui l'avait
qui jusque là n'avait pas touché
l'europe même si il ya déjà eu des il ya
déjà eu des moments où cette maladie est
arrivée en europe aux états unis oui oui
et oui les cas donc en grande bretagne
et puis il ya eu quand je suis en quelle
année je crois que les années 90 il ya
eu 73 cas je crois en grande bretagne ni
pardon des enfants qui ont été
dans le midwest est un peu partout qui
ont été contaminés par des chiens de
prairie qui eux mêmes avaient été en
contact avec des rongeurs et des
écureuils qui venaient d'afrique
centrale et qui enfin d'afrique de
l'ouest parce que je crois que c'est la
variante
de l'avarié de la variole du singe
d'afrique de l'ouest il ya deux de
souche principal est là il y en a deux
une considéré comme plus dangereuse que
l'autre
est celle d'afrique de l'ouest est
considéré comme moins dangereuse et
c'est celle qu'on constate se propager
actuellement en europe et aux états unis
et donc bref pour revenir il y avait
déjà eu des cas autochtones par non pas
des cas autochtones des cas a provoqué
c'était le réservoir de l'infection qui
avait été déplacée vial basse et voilà
et on parle de file du singe
effectivement mais c'est beaucoup de
côtés des rongeurs finalement que ce que
ça se transmet chez les animaux mais il
faut toucher des rongeurs ou toucher des
bd des primates qui seraient contaminés
quoi il ya plus de rongeurs que primates
dans les forêts africaines l
on s y être pour l'instant des
traitements qui sont qui sont mis en
place est ce qu'on sait comment traiter
cette maladie alors oui ça c'est nouveau
il n'y a pas de traitement spécifique
la variole du singe
20 contre la variole du singe
mais il ya des
vaccins qui existe et
voilà donc on préconise et alors c'est
très bizarre parce que hier la haute
autorité de santé en france a préconisé
enfin annoncé la préconisation d'un
vaccin mais il avait rendu déjà alors à
vie depuis quatre jours et voilà est
donc ce serait un vaccin qui serait
donnée au tout début de l'infection
de l'apparition des symptômes mais je
sais pas c'est pas très clair je me suis
tourné vers eux pour savoir c'est a
priori après l'apparition des symptômes
un vaccin qui serait donnée pour les
personnes qui auraient été conca contact
en fait sans comprendre cette notion de
cas contactez connais bien voilà grâce
malin grâce aux kabyles
donc entre quatre jours et deux semaines
après avoir été qu'un contact avec une
personne qui aurait elle développé la
maladie et qu'on donnerait donc au
personnel soignant et
aucun contact de cette personne voilà
donc ça c'est une préconisation de la
haute autorité de santé c'est un peu la
même chose qui est préconisé aux états
unis n'ont pas non pas aux états unis
encore mais en grande bretagne
donc vacciner les gens avec un vaccin
assez récents qui avec ses 1 contre la
variole et contre la variole du singe
spécifiquement je suis un peu surpris
parce que le
la haute autorité de santé annonce qu'il
ya eu une autorisation de mise sur le
marché en europe et aux états unis pour
ce vaccin mais un autre expert avec qui
j'ai parlé me disais que c'était un
médicament enfin un vaccin qui était
encore en phase iii il ça veut dire
qu'il n'a pas eu encore de test qui a
été fait sur une large population
voilà donc j'ai posé la question à
l'autorité de santé j'attends qu'ils me
répondent mais ils vont pas tarder à me
répondre c'est probable
ça c'est le sait la première méthode
prophylactique l'autre chose à faire
c'est surveillé le fait qu'ils aient pas
de surinfection parce que en tant que
telle la maladie généralement disparaît
naturellement après deux à quatre
semaines mais il peut y avoir les petits
boutons qui s'infectent des infections
bactériennes quelques amis il faut
traiter ces infections bactériennes
c'est sûr infections et on parle de à
10% de taux de mortalité est ce que du
coup on peut dire que c'est que cette
maladie est grave et peut être mortelle
sachant est ce que ces chiffres sont à
prendre telle qu'elle en tout cas ce
sont les chiffres de l'om est sain qui
donne ces chiffres de 1 à 10 %
effectivement
alors il faut voir que ça a été des
chiffres ont été calculés sur dans des
pays africains dans lequel la les
hôpitaux et là ce ne sont pas aussi
performants que les grands hôpitaux
d'europe ça c'est le premier point et
puis donc les risques de surinfection
sont pas forcément aussi bien prise en
charge est par ailleurs
les
il s'agit souvent enfin les personnes
les plus vulnérables sont des enfants
des femmes enceintes et des personnes
immunodéprimées et les enfants qui
vivent dans des conditions misérables en
afrique n'ont pas le même accès à la
médecine que
voilà comme chez nous effectivement du
coup on peut ce qu'on peut penser que
nous
7 cette maladie devraient disparaître
d'elle même pas ce qu'est ce qu'on s'est
un peu ce qui pourrait se passer dans
les prochains jours il y avait trois cas
annoncés hier il y en a 5 ce matin on
peut partir sur quelque chose d'
exponentielle est ce concert ne sais pas
parce que pour savoir combien de il faut
d'abord savoir combien ce qu'on appelle
le r0 c'est à dire combien une personne
malade va infecter d'autres personnes
combien qu'avait 16h01
le bien de personnes seront contaminées
par une personne qui est malade on ne le
connaît pas encore et personne ne la
calcule et donc il faut d'abord calculé
ce chiffre pour savoir si ce sera
exponentielle ou pas a priori on n'en
sait rien l' oms et les britanniques ont
annoncé qu' il fallait s'attendre à ce
que le nombre de malades augmente
effectivement il y avait cinq cas en
france on est je crois à 71 cas
en grande bretagne
voilà il ya prés pas tout à fait encore
mais près de 200 cas confirmés dans le
monde on était à 100 dimanche voilà donc
ça craint
mais est ce que ce sera quatre cent dans
quatre jours incapable de vous le dire
et ça dépend beaucoup des mesures qui
seront prises de
contingenter le l'évolution de la
maladie oui à voir comment comment
comment ça évolue effectivement alors
j'avais une autre d'autres questions
venant du chat je crois je vais essayer
de retrouver
n'est pas ici non déjà été posée est ce
que on peut parce qu'on nous parlait
tout à l'heure un pote qui nous parlait
du coc vide est ce que ce genre
d'apparition de maladies en france c'est
courant une est-ce qu'il ya eu d'autres
cas comme ça ou alors là c'est on est
deux ans après le coup vite donc du coup
on en parle beaucoup ou est ce que c'est
un fait assez récurrent alors je crois
qu'on est aussi deux ans après le coc
vide et que tout le monde est devenu
épidémiologistes et
experts des maladies donc voilà
peut-être c'est pour ça qu'on en parle
énormément
et puis les réseaux de surveillance se
sont améliorées dans la plupart des pays
le réseau de surveillance aux médias
donc quand on surveille les maladies et
là on a eu quand même l'habitude de
surveiller une maladie qu'on surveille
toujours d'ailleurs le coc vide reste
toujours très surveillé en france et
dans la plupart des pays occidentaux
on développe cette culture et donc on
regarde plus attentivement tout ce qui
peut apparaître donc je crois qu'il ya
un peu ce à quoi c'est à dire que quand
on regarde mieux ben on voit plus de
choses dont on trouve
justement en termes de surveillance ont
paraît il ya des pays qui sont entre
guillemets en avance sur nous par
exemple la grande bretagne qui a plus de
cas est ce que dans ces cas là on va
plutôt voir comment eux se débrouille
pour voir nous plus tard si on a une ou
deux semaines c'est un peu ce qui
s'était passé avec le coach croit haut
niveau l'italie est ce que c'est quelque
chose qui peut être
adapté comme cela
le réseau de surveillance
en grande bretagne le réseau de
surveillance au danemark était bien
meilleur et sont toujours meilleurs que
les nôtres hélas
il repère de manière beaucoup plus
précise les variants du rhdp rennes
manière beaucoup plus précise les
variants du covin par rapport à la
france et je me rappelle qu'en début
d'année dernière on disait le variant
alpha
oui on a deux mois 3 - et c'est en fait
on était à dix quinze jours trois
semaines maximum du de ce qui se passait
en grande bretagne donc les choses vont
un petit peu plus vite il faut avoir de
bonnes loupe et puis bien regarder les
indicateurs qu'on a alors mais ceci
étant c'est très probable que le ja que
cinq cas en france enfin peut-être 7,8
aujourd'hui et puis pas loin de 80 en
grande bretagne
voilà donc il faut s'inspirer de ce que
font les meilleurs et d'ailleurs l'avis
de la haute autorité de santé récent sur
la vaccination fait référence à la
décision de la grande-bretagne qui a été
la première à être enfin le loto de l'as
l'autorité de santé britannique a été la
première à suggérer l'utilisation du
vaccin pour le personnel soignant voilà
les mânes une semaine après on dira oui
ce serait bien de faire comme la grande
bretagne et d'ailleurs le le vaccin
qu'on préconise qu'on aurait paraît-il
d'après la ministre dans nos stocks
stratégiques
c'est le même
pour répondre un peu à la question que
les gens se pose est-ce qu'il faut
s'inquiéter de ce virus dont il faut pas
s'inquiéter outre mesure en tout cas
pour l'instant très bien merci beaucoup
marque en tout cas d'avoir été avec nous
aujourd'hui merci à vous d'avoir été
nombreux à suivre cela il va nous poser
vos questions et moi je vous dis à
bientôt pour de nouveaux lives sur
figaro live